fue el choque de un cometa gigante en
Júpiter lo que sirvió de advertencia
para los científicos en la tierra en
1994 el nuevo sistema de defensa
planetaria de la NASA comenzó a observar
cientos de millones de asteroides casi
30 años después Un nuevo capítulo
comenzó con Dark la nave espacial se
estrelló contra un asteroide para tratar
de desviar su órbita el objetivo es
poner en marcha una técnica que permita
un día desplazar asteroides que amenazan
a nuestro planeta
Queremos saber si podemos desviar un
asteroide si nuestra tecnología puede
permitirnos golpearlo darle un pequeño
empujón alejarlo probando la desviación
de asteroides
el problema no son los grandes
asteroides de más de un kilómetro porque
sabemos que ninguno nos amenaza
actualmente se trata más bien de objetos
lo suficientemente Grandes como para
hacernos daño pero de pequeños para
detectarlos a tiempo existe la
posibilidad de que un asteroide de unos
100 metros cruce Nuestro camino Dentro
de 20 años
en ese caso la nave espacial de impacto
podrá ser extremadamente eficaz la
agencia espacial europea enviará su
propia misión al lugar del impacto para
examinar el asteroide su misión utilizar
los datos para generar una técnica que
pueda servir para desviar cualquier
objeto importante en los próximos años
[Música]